I don't think education is about teaching people.
I think it's about people learning.
And there's a big difference.
One of my first math teachers, you know, he said he's going to respect us not for the answers we give...
...but for the questions we ask.
And he turned my learning world upside down.
Because how I have to listen to something in order to ask an intelligent question....
...is a lot more than how I have to listen in order to give an intelligent answer.
Because, you know, an intelligent answer you can do half - asleep.
An intelligent question you have to have at least one eye open.
When my kids started playing with Wikipedia,...
...they were being accused of, you know, "That's not the way to do your homework."
Now, what am I expecting to see?
We are already at the stage where an enlightened teacher will tell their students,...
..."Your job is to write a Wikipedia article."
And then the power of saying, "Wow, immediately I'm gonna put something up that 300 million people are gonna read."
"I'd better get this right."
Human beings like participating.
Human beings like doing things.
They like a level of variety in what they do.
They like a level of freedom in what they do.
And we've lost all these.
So, I think you'll suddenly find that the idea of a school having walls disappears, okay.
Parents are part of a school.
Friends are part of a school.
That's why I say learning is a philosophy.
It's a state of mind.